[تصفيق]
ايوه
قلت لي خربت عليك دائره الباور حق الجهاز
والجهاز واقف عليك
ما فيش لغه قطع غيار
ولازم انك تنزله من الخارج ويتاخر بيحتاج
وقت
وشغلك واقف يعتمد على الجهاز
طيب الجهاز اللي عندي للمحل بشوف مواصفات
الجهاز بصمم لك على دائره
ايوه ايوه
على حسب مواصفات الجهاز
واصل
نعمه الله دومي يقول لك الاجهزه اللي
تصلحها ما فيش منها فايده الحمد لله
انتم مركزين معي
اكيد مستغربين ان انا اقول له بصنع لك ولا
تنزلش من برا هذا هو انا اسرع اعرف وهذه
هي شغل وهذه هي الشغله ببساطه اقوم بتصنيع
اجهزه بسيطه متواضعه جدا واكتب عليها
منتجات محليه رغبه مني في اظهار المنتج
المحلي ورغبه وطموح مني ان تصبح بلدنا بلد
مصدره ومنتجه فعلا
البعض يخطر في باله السؤال ويقول معقول
اصبح بلد مصدره وبلد منطقه
معقول احنا بلد الازمات وبلاد المشاكل
نصبح بلد تنتج معقول انا نصبح منتجين
كل واحد ولازم انه احترمه وجهه نظركم تجاه
المشاكل الازمات النحل عائق الاساسي تجاه
هذا الموضوع لكن انا اللي واجهه نظر خاصه
بي
قبل ثمان سنوات من الان في النصف الاخير
من 2015 كانت الازمه كبيره جدا بالنسبه لي
لما الدكتور فجاه يقول لي ياسر من بعد
اليوم انت ممنوع تشتغل اي شغل عضلي لمده
سنتين ابعد السنتين بنشوف موضوعك اذا كنت
بتقدر ترجع وبنزيد فتره نقاهتك فكانت ازمه
مشكله جدا كبيره بالنسبه لي بعد ما كنت
اشتغل في التكييف والتبريد واشتغل في
التمديدات الكهربائيه زي واحد يتعلم من
ابوه مهنه الكهربائيات وتكييف التبريد
فكيف انت الان يا دكتور تقول لي ممنوع انك
حتى تطلع سلم عشان تركب لمبه بعد ما كنت
تعلمت الكهربائيات بشكل سريع جدا لانك انت
تحبها في اول ثانوي كنت تاخد مقاولات
عليها
فكيف الان يا دكتور تقول لي ممنوع انك حتى
تدخل الورشه مع ابوك بعد ما كنت اسيب
الشغل بسيب اللعب مع اصحابي في ذاك السن
واروح اتعلم مع ابي في الورشه
فكانت ازمه جدا قويه بالنسبه لي لكن في
كلمه كانت تجيلي دائما وهي من من فم
الوالده الله يحفظها ويعطيها الصحه
والعافيه فقالت دائما تقول لي ياسر ربي ما
قفل عليك هذا الباب الا عشان يفتح لك باب
جديد اصبر في حاجه بتجيلك فكان تقول ام
تحاول تواسي ابنه هذه يوم ثانيه لكن يا
جماعه الامه حاجه عجيبه الامه حاجه عظيمه
جدا
فعلا يا اما دائما الام هي الصح يا اما
دائما احنا الغلط ربي يوفقها ويخليها الصح
ما ادريش
المهم مرات الايام
بعد ما كانت حياتي مرتبه على شغل رياضه
دراسه اصبح الشغل الرياضه ممنوع ياسر خذ
الدراسه وطلعها في الاولويه وارجع
للثانويه رجعت للثانويه فقال في يوم من
الايام وانا في الثانويه اشوف لائحه كبيره
مكتوب عليها الملتقى الثقافي للاختراع
الابتكار معقول اختراع ابتكار نحن في
نهايه 2015 نحن خارجين من حرب في عندنا
مخترعين في عندنا مبتكرين ادخل ياسر شوف
ايش موجود معاهم ادخل اشوف
لمبه مروحه حساس طيب هذه الاشياء انا كنت
اشتغلها في الواقع كنت اخذ يعني شغلات
كهرباء اشياء موجوده عندك كان في شعورك
هذا المكان انت قادر تشارك فيه رحت عند
الاستاذ المشرفه استاذه ممكن اشارك معاكم
قالت لي ممكن تشارك بس بشرط
شرط انك لازم تجي بكره ومعك فكره انا اول
مره اشارك في هذا الموضوع لازم تجي بكره
ومعك فكره عشان تكفيك الثلاث ايام
المتبقيه انك تجهز مشروعك
اقل بكره او نسميه اليوم التالي
ورحت
الى المدرسه
وانا حامل او بالاصح الثانويه وانا حامل
هذا البرميل او لعائشه الغريب وحطيته على
مركز المديره او المشرفه قلت لها استاذه
هذا هو مشروعي
بعد ما كانوا يظنوا ان هذا مجرد مقسم كانت
الدهشه غريبه وصادمه بالنسبه لهم لما لقيت
وشغلت هذا المجسم واكتشفوا بالنهايه انه
عباره عن مكنسه كهربائيه واقعيه وتشتغل
فعلا
فكان في ذيك الايام انجاز بالنسبه لي انا
سويت مكنسه كهربائيه نرجع يوم قبل اليوم
اللي قبل لما روحت من الثانويه ايش اللي
خلانا اختار هذه الفكره وانا في الطريق
معقول ممنوع تشتغل كهرباء وممنوع تشتغل
كيف تبريد والام مش موفق حتى ان انا اشارك
مشاركه في هذا المجال فشفت محل كهربائيات
مسجل عليه مكانس كهربائيه قربنا شعور عند
اصحاب التشليح اتفرج على التشليح في
امكانيه في قدره انك قادر اسوي هذه
الحاجات سويتها وسويتها وشاركت في
المسابقه وكان اول انجاز لي ان انا اشارك
في مسابقه اختراعه ابتكار واروح شهاده
حلوه اننا الاول على مستوى المحافظه في
الابتكار والاختراع وكان درع الابداع
انجاز اروح لعند امي تقول لي هذا الطريق
الجديد اللي كنت اكلمك عليه في طريق جديد
اقاله طيب طريق جديد بس في حاجه مختلفه
انا كنت لما اروح من الشغل اروح بمردود
مادي الان روحت بهذي الشهاده فرحان فيها
اوكي تحت دقيق مستوى بس بحطها في الكبت
وانتهى الموضوع معقول كذا
استغليت التكنولوجيا وحبيت اطلع على
الموضوع اكثر ايش هذا الموضوع اللي انا
لغيته مركز اول وانا مش داري ايش هو اصلا
ادخل على التكنولوجيا اتفرج تغذيه بصريه
فقط بدون ما اخذ فيديوهات تعليميه
فيديوهات عن الخارج الغرب ايش موجود معاهم
الدول المتحضره ايش موجود معاهم الابتكار
اللي موجود عندهم ايش الروبوت تغذيه بصريه
فقط في بدايه 2016
كانت معانا مشكله داخل البيت مشكله عويصه
جدا
انه في يوم او يومين من اسبوع يكون البيت
في حاله استنفار لما الفجر وهو يوم الميت
يوم نجلس كلنا سهرانين راغب المضخه راغب
الخزان شوفوا
فكانت في كلمات معايره تصدر من الاهل هيا
يا مخترع شوف لنا
حلنا حاجه وفعلا كانت هذه الكلمات سبب ان
انا سويت لهم جهاز بسيط بسيط جدا داخل
البيت انه يوري لي مستوى المي داخل خزان
مليان ولا مش مليون لما يمتلي الخزان
يعطينا طيط انذار ويطفي المضخات تلقائيا
وكنت في ذيك الايام احب ان انا اصور
الحاجات اللي اسويها وان مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
فجاء الاستاذه تتصل عليه وتقول لي الو
ياسر احنا شفنا حقك الجهاز اللي انت عرضته
في النت واحنا نواجه نفس المشكله جهاز
عشان ما نكونش نسهر
وشوف لنا كم بيكلف
كم بيكلف هذه كانت عليها اكثر من الف
حاصره والف خط معقول التجارب البسيطه اللي
بسويها استفيد منها مردود مادي
تمام اوكي استاذ انا مستعد اني اسوي لك بس
في مشكله ايش المشكله ان حق الجهاز يسويه
شكله المظهر مش حلو قالت ما يهمش المهم ان
احنا ما نسهرش تمام الجهاز واعطيتها
الجهاز وكان زبون ورا زبون يجي ويطلبوا
الجهاز اصبح هذا الموضوع هو الطريق الجديد
اللي كانت امي فعلا تكلمنا عنه اصبحت
دائما داخل البيت اشوف ايش المشكله اللي
موجوده معانا داخل البيت
ايش المشكله معانا داخل البيت ماطور مولد
ايش حاجه جديده عمل لها حل وعمل لها منتج
وابيع فاصبح وشغلي
هو رغبتين هو طموحي
في نهايه 2016 بعد دخولي في هذا المجال
لمده سنه الحمد لله اصبحت مدرب اقيم دورات
في المعهد اللي تحت على اساس ان انا اخذ
دورات فيه اغير دورات على الالكترونيات
والانظمه المدمجه وبعض من مواضيع الروبوت
وكان في ذيك الفتره مشكله اعاني منه انه
كان احيانا يقولي خريجين او اصحاب
الماجستير او اصحاب البكالوريوس باستشورها
استشيرونا في بعض مواضيع من هذه المواضيع
وكنت انا خرج سنويا
فكنت اعاني من مشكله المصطلحات ما افهمها
لذلك كانت هي السبب اللي دخلتنا كليه
والان على وشك انها تخرج من كليه الهندسه
اللي دخلتها عشان اواجه مشكله المصطلحات
في 2018
كانت في مشكله عويصه جدا وطموح اشتي اوصل
له
كانت في فئه احب ان انا اوصل له لحل لهم
فئه ذوي الاعاقه او فئات الاشخاص اللي
اصيبوا بعد الحرب في اشخاص صيبوا بعض
الحرب ادت اصابتهم انه ما عاد تقدر حتى
يتحرك ادت اصابته انك حتى لو تعطيك كرسي
معاقين ما يقدر يستفيد منه لانه ما يقدر
يحرك يده فكيف ممكن تحل هذه المشكله انا
بعد ما كانت حياتي خلاص ان انا اشوف اي
مشكله واجيب لها جهاز لازم ان انا احل هذا
وكان هذا حلم بالنسبه لي ان انا اجيب لهم
حاجه يتحكموا فيها عن طريق الدماغ اشتي
هذا الشخص من معاق يجلس داخل البيت كذا
يلصي ويطفي الحاجه اللي في البيت بدون ما
يتحرك يحرك الكرسي اللي موجود معه بدون ما
يتحرك فكان حلم بالنسبه لي بس كنت كل ما
اروح عند صديق او صاحب او اي شخص يا اخي
كيف ايش رايك لو اتحكم عن طريق الموجات
الدماغيه
فاحنا مجتمع متنمر روح لك يا ساحر بتحكم
عن طريق الدماغ
فعلا جزعات الايام وجيت في يوم من الايام
خرجت اصحابي ومعي هذا الكرسي واتحكم فيه
عن طريق الموجات الدماغيه
وكان انجاز بالنسبه لي ولكن
خرجت عشان استلم لقبل جديد اللي يتحكم
بالحاجات براسه
فايضا ب 2019 اقعد جائحه كورونا جائحه
كورونا كانت مشكله كبيره بالنسبه لنا
وتوقفت عنا المدخلات الخارجيه لبلادنا وقف
الدخل من الخارج فكيف ممكن نواجه هذه
المشكله ونواجه مشكله ايقاف المسيره
التعليميه
فحل هذه المشكله وجيب منتجات لازم لازم
انك تجيب حاجه لازم تبحث بعد ما صرت على
قناعه ان البيئه اللي فيها مشكله هي بيئه
خصبه لانتاج المهاره وان البيئه اللي فيها
ازمات هي بيئه الابداعات فكنا نشوف في
فتره كورونا ايش الابداعات اللي طلعت في
المجتمعنا وكلنا نعرفه ما نقال
قمنا بتصميم بوابات تعقيم الكترونيات
تلقائيه كانت على شكل منتج وكان هذا انجاز
بسيط ايضا
فانا لما اتكلم معكم الان ما اتكلم معكم
على اننا قصه نجاح لا انا مش قصه نجاح ولا
حتى وصلت ل15% من الشاوصل له بس نوصل باذن
الله
ولا اتكلم معك على اننا مخترع او مبتكر
لان هذه التقنيات وهذه الاشياء قد سبقونا
فيها كثير من الباحثين والمعلمين
والمهندسين بس الفرق شاسع بين من يعمل
التجربه على شكل تجربه فقط وتنتهي بانتهاء
نجاحها يعني عملت تجربه نجحت التجربه خلاص
انا كملت وبين من يعمل التجربه وتبدا
تجربته بعد نجاحها نجاحات التجربه يشوف
كيف ممكن يسقطها على ارض الواقع كيف ممكن
استفيد منها واقعيا فانت كاستاذ او معلم
او حتى دكتور واجب عليك لما الطالب
المعلومه اعطيه المعلومه ملموسه بوقائعيات
كيف ممكن يستفيد من هذا الشيء بالواقع كيف
ممكن يخرج الارض الواقع ويستفيد من هذا
نكمل هائل من المعلومات في ارض الواقع
وانت كطالب واجب عليك لما تاخذ المعلومه
من الاستاذ ما تكتفي بالمعلومه او تقربه
فقط خذ هذه الافكار خذ افكارك وانزلها على
ارض الواقع اظهر شيء انت قادر تخرج انت
فيك راسك كم مهايل من معلومات والتجارب
اللي مارسها في داخل مسيرتك التعليميه
اسقطها على ارض الواقع واعصر تغادر تستطيع
عشان ما تتخرج بعدين وتروح بشهادتك هذه
وتجلس تتعذر في الوظائف انت قادر تنتج
قادر تصنع فعلا
انت كتاجر او مسؤول وصاحب راس مال اهتم
بالمنتج المحلي المنتج المحلي قوه المنتج
المحلي الاقتصاد المنتج المحلي لماء واذا
ما تحب تدخل في سوق المنتج المحلي برضو
حلو عشان ما تكون منافس بالنسبه لي
انت كسلطه
يسر ويسهل على اصحاب المشاريع الصغيره
وبالاخص المشاريع الانتاجيه المشاريع
الانتاجيه هي القوه للبلد اذا كنا ندور
القوه للبلد فعلا الاكتفاء الذاتي هو قوات
البلد والاكتفاء الذاتي ما يجي الا
بالمنتج المحلي فنهتم بالمنتج المحلي
[تصفيق]
معك اثنين مولدات خمسين كيلو
تمام نصمم لك وليش لا معنا تربه الله يا
جماعه
[تصفيق]